my guest today is dr warren farrell who
is a new york times best-selling author
written many different books he's been
on many different tv shows i'm talking
oprah winfrey phil donahue
wrote a book called the myth of male
power as well as boy the boy crisis he's
got millions of views online and he's
very comfortable making others
uncomfortable and i would even take it
as far as he's very comfortable
sometimes
unintentionally or intentionally pissing
other people off so with that being said
doc thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
[Music]
why do you think some people get
uncomfortable when you talk about
you know i i don't know what university
was you were speaking at
people were writing against you
protesting against you they were not
happy about you speaking some people
just wanted to hear your argument but
they tried to silence your message why
do you think this message of the boy
crisis
you know some people have a hard time
listening to
well to answer that question we're going
to have to go deep quickly
which is that historically and
biologically
men were programmed to be disposable
and we would be programmed to be
disposable to be uh able to save the
lives of women
so every generation had its war and
every generation had some version of
uncle sam saying we need you
um and and they and we we all knew as
males that you know uncle joe who was in
the marines was the respected um person
in the family and we wanted to be you
know we were being criticized by our
parents we wanted to be respected so we
accept the social bribe what i call the
social bribe of being called hero
to get that type of respect and then
women learn to fall in love with the
officer and the gentleman not the
private and the pacifist
so we knew we would be if we were
willing to risk our lives to save women
to save children to save other men um
save the country uh that we would be
more loved we would be uh the person
that was you know fallen in love with um
by the woman who wanted the officer and
the gentleman and not that private in
the pacifist uh we learned on some level
that lois lane had no interest in clark
kent of the same person in superman
uniform uh what she fell in love with
and so we
so when when men complain uh women are
programmed to fall in love with alpha
men not whining men
and so when men complain it spiels to
women like
let's say a chalk on a blackboard
scratching his nails scratching on a
blackboard how he feels it doesn't feel
right to women women instinctively
withdraw from men who express
what concerns them
they want them to be there to deal with
what concerns the women and so
in the in the process of becoming
successful as a man
is inversely related to the process
of becoming successful in love and so
since we have a lot of entrepreneurs in
the line i'll be glad to take that one
at a much deeper level but
that's the
the underlying biological and historical
background as to why we don't we're not
as empathetic to boys and men
complaining or expressing their hurt
their pain their feelings their fears
now you know to go to go and i want to
unpack that but to go back where the
audience kind of knows your history
you're not somebody that started
thinking like this your entire life you
were originally part of the
uh feminist movement matter of fact i
think there's a picture with you and
gloria steinem who was the spokes person
or spoken or even the leader for the
american feminist movement in america
and uh you were kind of going in that
direction can you kind of walk us
through your history and what made you
flip and switch
yes first of all i don't feel i have
flipped and switched but it's definitely
true that um i was the only man ever
elected three times to the board of
directors of the national organization
for women in new york city and i spoke
all around the world on women's issues
and
and my income came completely from
speaking around the world on women's
issues and i i suppose i was probably
the um
the best known male spokesperson for
women's issues and so i guess that was
very close to gloria steinem betty
friedan and all the initial leaders of
the women's movement
and i think things began to
and so i i never considered i always
considered myself i would say
a gender a person in favor of a gender
liberation movement i never wanted women
to be criticizing men or women's
movement to be focused on criticizing
men i never wanted a men's movement to
be focused on criticizing women i always
wanted both sexes to understand that for
the first time in human history
we had an opportunity to not be
dominated by not patriarchy but because
i don't think we were dominated by
patriarchy we were dominated by a need
to survive
and to survive
women and men in most societies played
roles women's role was essentially
raised children men's role was
essentially raised money
women didn't feel that they would get
much social praise so uh they had social
bribes to be mothers and to raise those
children and to do that well and men had
social bribes that you weren't worth
much of anything if you didn't
either participate in the possibility of
being disposable in war
or being disposable in the workplace
either by
working the hazardous jobs or by
working 60 70 80 hours a week where you
might die at the desk from stress and
overwork uh but your job was to earn
enough money to be able to support not
just your wife and your children and so
you didn't think much of yourself and
other people didn't think of much of you
if you are an unemployed person living
in your family's basement um and hoping
that a woman would save you but you were
really good looking and uh sweet and
kind and had a good emotional
intelligence
so
then maybe let me ask the question
differently
i'm sorry i didn't
do the second part of that question
which is how you know what made me
evolve from that and i thought but you
said you said not much has so let me let
me ask the question in a different way
so
if you've been the same from the 60s and
70s till today
then it would only be the right question
to ask has
the movement of feminism changed from
what it originally was to what it is
today
the answer is three answers to that yes
yes and yes
yeah got it so the the original focus in
the women's movement was
um that there was that you know helen
ready i am woman i am strong um it has
increasingly become
i am one i've been wronged
hashtagged me too i've been wronged um
women and then and then uh there was
always an anti-male dimension to the
feminist movement even in the early days
my former wife who was a very wonderful
woman
said to me you know you don't want to
get involved with the women's movement
it's really anti a lot of anti-male and
my response was well it may be anti-male
for a while but i don't think that that
will um increase um as men start
listening to it and men and women men
and women's roles tend to change and to
modify i think both sexes roles will
change and modify however i do think
men's roles will change much more slowly
than women's roles will change and my
former wife um said it was that because
you feel men have the power i said no
they don't have the power to speak up
about the limitations of their roles uh
we
are we are programmed to protect women
and to be able to do what women ask for
and right now women are the first ones
speaking up um to be able to be more
flexible at who they want to be
to be able to when children come
women express
because
they have three choices um choice number
one is to be full-time with the children
if they're married in middle class or
above
your choice number two is to be
full-time with the workplace um choice
number three is to be
part work part-time
and men also have you know say well we
have three options too and option one is
to work full-time option two is to work
full-time option three is to work
full-time or if they're working class
men to work to um jobs and if they're a
a corporate executive it's too um or uh
in involved in their middle and upper
middle class man it's often to work more
hours at the same job or to become more
successful so a person who was a local
sales person for product x
might feel
much more inclined to accept a position
as national sales person but as a
national sales
he finds himself um leaving his um
experiencing the father's
couch 22 and the father's catch 22 is
learning to love his family by being
away from the love of his family
and um and so he um then feels he's he's
he's doing this increased amount of
money earning to be able to give his
families his family options that he
never had he wants to buy a better home
and a better neighborhood with a better
school system for his kids
and a better home for both his wife and
his kids and and so he gets caught up in
that but then spends less and less time
for the kids and wife that he really
loves and he's working for until
sometimes he does things that he learns
he learns things to be successful at
work
that are the opposite of what it takes
to be successful in love and he doesn't
know that he's doing that and the wife
and the wife and children don't know
that he's doing that but you know i'll
be happy to share with you what that
tension is now that often leads to many
successful men um ending up getting
divorced or not getting divorced because
their wife needs the security
economically that he provides but he
senses underneath uh that his wife is
really hanging around to to love the
children and have that security rather
than feeling loved himself
well let me let me ask this do
so common reasons why women get a
divorce common reasons why men get a
divorce it's a different in my family i
i've seen both
uh my dad filed a divorce against my mom
so it was more from that side but from
your experience what are reasons why men
filed for divorce over women filing for
divorce well bigger picture first
when
women have a college education
they are 92
of the people who are
filed for divorce when they don't have
an education much like they've only
graduated from high school as opposed to
college um they're the percentages are
lower um has so
why so what
was that why so um
because when a woman has economic
security she
needs the man less for economic security
she senses that if she sues she if she's
a plaintiff she has some advantages
legally that
that allow her to be to make it
likely that she will both get um a
significant amount of economic security
in the future and will also prompt the
children he she basically has the right
to the children he has to fight for the
children and he has to if he fights for
the children it will cost him maybe
125 000 to a quarter million dollars to
fight for the children
and uh that that oftentimes
it just breaks his heart so men and
women who go who are going through
family court
men often get so depressed by the
process that they're eight times as
likely as the mother is
to commit suicide
and so it's it's a very
um challenging process and because the
the court system is really designed
at its current um
state um to um
when a woman most judges feel that
children do best with both parents have
to divorce that's accurate and most
judges agree with that however when a
woman says i'm afraid of my husband not
just physically but you know he might he
shouts at me and he raises his voice and
she gives a couple of examples of that
then the judge often fears um
um giving the custody equally to both
sexes
because if there's one time out of a
thousand um that that in fact you know
that man um is violent or uh physically
abuses the woman or just uh overly
shouts at the woman and she records it
on a video cam uh that he feel he
becomes he or she the judge becomes
vulnerable to um being um
losing her his position as a judge
okay so so why do men file the divorce
and you know again
you hear stories about women
why are some reasons why men follow
divorce yeah well first of all both
sexes file for divorce largely because
neither sex feels heard
that is the single biggest problem the
achilles heel of all human beings is our
inability to handle personal criticism
without becoming defensive
and that's true of both men and women
when men do file for divorce it's often
because they um they feel that they just
can't take it anymore uh they feel that
their alcoholism or their
ideations of suicide
or
the the feeling that the uh the mother
really doesn't like him anymore not even
just not love him but not like him
um and and then often and then usually
somewhere along the way particularly if
he's an executive or a corporate person
and he moves around a lot and owns his
own business he might go from branch to
branch of his of his business and
eventually meet somebody that really he
feels respects him oftentimes his own
secretary might
be much more respectful of him than his
wife and um and so he feels like there's
somebody else that can love me that does
understand me that that is proud of me
um and um and verse and then he has an
affair with her um and um
and that leads uh to him feeling that um
and then usually the new woman
wants uh wants more than just an affair
wants some security wants some lifetime
intimacy he does too and so that
accounts for the eight percent um of
people who are men that file for divorce
usually and or the greater percentage of
the woman has um
um less of a of an education and is less
likely to file um then um that starts
increasing to about 20 25
of males filing for divorce
so so doc you know the boy crisis i mean
the
crisis of education christ of mental
health crisis of father and crisis of
purpose you know you you talk about this
and then i saw one of your speeches
where you're talking about at the age of
nine
boys and girls suicide rate is the same
at 10 or 14 boys are twice
the chance of committing suicide then
the girls do twice the amount of
suicides as boys as girls do
15 to 19 it's four times the amount boys
to girls
20 to 25 it's six times the amount boys
to girls so if you don't if you don't
mind unpacking the boys crisis i have
some follow-ups whether anything to do
with the upper again has to do with the
divorce but i'd like to start with the
boy crisis first
yes
when i first submitted my proposal to
my publisher for the boy crisis book
i had 10 causes of the boy crisis i was
going to write a chapter in each
and then the more i studied it the more
i realized that the single most
important cause by a long shot was that
basically the boy crisis resides where
dads do not reside
um and when boys don't have when when
usually
when there's one parent
in the game um and the other parent
minimally involved or not at all
involved it's usually the mother that's
the primary parent and the the dad
that's the secondary parent and in those
situations the girls have challenges and
more than the daughters have challenges
in more than 50 different areas
but the boys have challenges in more
than 50 different areas also but their
challenges are more intense they're more
likely to commit suicide than the girls
are by the by the data that you just
gave they're more likely to move into
depression when you remember when you
measure depression come by male
standards which is almost completely
unheard of as opposed to just the female
measures of depression almost all of our
measures of depression our female
measures the boys are much more likely
to become addicted to video games uh
girls and boys both play video games
video games are very healthy at a
reasonable proportional amount of level
to the rest of life
but when it comes to addiction to video
games boys are far more likely to be
addicted to video games than than girls
are
um boys are far more likely to be
addicted to drugs to alcohol um their
depression leads them to feeling that
they're they're worthless and they
become ashamed of themselves and
they fear that they're going to be
rejected by girls so they're much more
likely to turn into pornography because
pornography is basically access
to a variety of attractive women without
fear of rejection
at a price they can afford
and so guys as they as they don't do as
well in school
they don't feel as admired by girls
girls tend to date winners not losers
and so they feel that they're a loser
and that they fear that they can't risk
rejection because they know that the the
girls they're most attracted to are
taking the quarterbacks or the student
body president or some other guy that's
really sharp
and on the basketball team etc
and so they start
fearing um becoming introspective
becoming withdrawn becoming rebellious
becoming um
very coercive to their parents and their
they feel badly about themselves and
that leads them into depression into
suicide into drinking into drugs into
death from opioid overdoses and into
addiction to pornography
and so and that addiction to pornography
is very dangerous because what happens
from for boys
who are addicted to pornography is that
you know the first time
they they are watching pornography and
just watching a woman
an attractive woman take her clothes off
is really exciting for them but after
they've watched that 15 times it loses
the the excitement and so they have to
keep upping the ante until uh they're um
requiring things like um the only way
they can get turned on is a woman doing
something like um
letting him come in her face and so but
then they finally get a woman that is
really interested in being with them and
the woman um is um and they get together
and she and he wants to do that and she
goes you know and withdraws because she
feels treated like a porn object because
she's being treated like a porn object
and so that's really um very um
challenging um for the woman and
therefore is challenging for the
guy as well have you ever spoken to
pamela anderson
i have never spoken to pamela anderson
no i think it may not be a bad idea to
speak to her because one of the things
she talks to her boys about is
when she says sometimes when i would go
home with a guy they would try to have
sex with me as if they watched the porn
and she said i taught my boys don't have
sex with girls with what you see in porn
because that's not how they like it i
think it's a very good conversation for
the two of you guys to have but that's a
completely different subject that's just
a suggestion for you so i would agree
with her 100 yeah so going back to uh
going back to what we're talking about
here with porn
uh the the visual you gave was very
helpful
uh i'm sure it inspired a lot of people
to make some bright adjustments in their
lives uh uh so
but uh going back to this so you talk
about a fatherless boys okay
and statistics we see nowadays and the
consequences of it one
uh what is the number between fatherless
boys and motherless boys is it a 98 to
two like the boys that are raised
without a mother how small of a
percentage is that well we don't even
have a lot of data on it
yes um boy boys are far more likely to
be raised by their mom than their dad
it's about a nine to one ratio
nine-to-one ratio okay so so let me let
me go a little bit more deeper without
the question so so boys okay so we know
that we know that's going to be taking
place is there an event that
incentivized
incentivized uh
you know mothers to say i don't need a
man to help me raise my kids i can do it
on my own or has this number nine to one
been historically the same where we've
had a lot of you know fatherless
you know homes where boys are raised
without a father is there is there a
trend that took place
very good question and uh the answer is
what in the 53 largest developed nations
with the emphasis on the word developed
in developed nations survival is not as
big an issue in the middle and upper
middle class as it is in less developed
nations
when survival is not as big an issue the
society starts giving more permission
for there to be
divorces if you want that because you're
moving from
survival what you need to what you want
and if two people are unhappy most
societies that are developed allow some
permission for divorce
the churches are usually not as
significant a role they play a role um
but the
pressure to to not be just uh to be
disgraced at yourself if you uh if you
get a divorce is not as great
so you have
so in the
end you have more freedom to raise
children um by yourself if you're a
woman so in the united states at the
present moment 53 percent of
women who have children who are under 30
have have uh children without being
married
um and
in general
without the under 30 part put in uh 42
of women in the united states at the
present moment who have children have
children without being married
most of the time even among those
who who have who are not married but
they're living with a man at the time
that they have children those
relationships last on average about
three years
and then usually after that three years
the children
have minimal or no contact with the dad
uh when there's a split up and so the
boy crisis resides
among those boys who have minimal or no
contact with the dead and even and
they've had that contact for the first
few years but then they feel abandoned
and lost by that dad and boys you know
the girls at least have the role model
of a mother as to what it is to be a a
female but the boys don't have the role
model of a father or if they have a role
model the father that father after the
mother and father break up or the father
is often bad mouthed by the mother he's
very narcissistic that's why we broke up
he's very self-centered and he's very
he's not reliable he's not um
you know he's a liar things like that
and the boy begins to look in the mirror
and worry that maybe he's looking in the
mirror because he's a narcissist or he's
you know he remembers lying to this a
friend of his or he remembers being
unreliable in this way or that way and
he begins to fear that the qualities
that
that the father is being condemned for
that led to the breakup of the mother
and father are also qualities that he
has and but he can't talk to the father
about that because that'll only
destabilize the relationship when the
father and mother have a fight can't
talk to the mother about that from the
same destabilization fear and so he just
shuts up about that keeps that inside of
himself and it becomes a problem that
leads to you know depending on the
personality of the boy it either leads
to minor problems or very major
psychological problems that that
oftentimes boys don't go to the
psychologist and they don't work those
things out
and so among divorced families
the challenge is even greater
because the the children are often
seeing the mother and father argue
the the arguments are not compassionate
arguments where gee i heard you say this
tell me more about what you said that i
had to sort anything about um here's
what i heard you said did i distort
anything am i missing anything is there
anything more that you want to ask
sweetheart
tell me more that is not the
conversation that the the children of
divorce tend to hear
and so for the past 30 years i've been
conducting couples communication
workshops around the country because i
wanted to prevent the divorces i wanted
children to have
parents that had happy relationships
positive relationships that that had
that had differences of opinion but they
knew how to hear each other to work
those differences through and so
therefore there would as a result of
that be fewer divorces and therefore
they would as a result of that um be
fewer boys that didn't have uh very much
father involvement and so um i've sort
of gone back to the root cause of the
boy crisis which really wasn't um boys
alone but it was
families breaking up
builder boys not having a dad to work
with and not having good communication
role models
in their parents and therefore those
boys and the daughters of these of these
divorced families are far more likely to
have divorces themselves uh when and and
bad communication um methods as they
grow up
do our taxes does our tax system benefit
uh
single mothers
having more kids without relying on a
husband just to say you know if i have
another kid i'm going to make an
additional xyz amount of money per year
so i don't need another man because i'm
going to get a benefit that's coming
from the government
does that take into account because
again as somebody that's been in the
financial industry all i'm looking for
is data to show me what flip did a tax
incentive flip did a new program flip
did a new method of teaching in our
educational system flip what was it that
caused this to become
the number that it is today
the main flip was the option of
developed nations that didn't have to
worry about survival
the second flip
was the government became a substitute
husband
when it started to make
laws saying that if a woman
didn't have a man that she was living
with or was not married to a man
that she could get money from the
government
and so the government became a
substitute husband and this was
institutionalized through many many
programs like women infants and children
which makes it clear that it's not men
infants and children it's not couples
infants and children it's not infants
whose parents don't make enough money
so particularly in inner-city
communities where that were poor
oftentimes and particularly in
african-american black communities uh
there was often times the the the black
male uh was not making a lot of money
and in those cases what he wasn't um the
woman and the black male um both usually
a black woman and a black male man
calculated that there was um a an
inadequate amount of money that was
coming from the father to support the
children effectively so she
made sure that the father did not live
with her and so then
so she could get the money from the
government
and that money came in multiple forms
but not just through the women infants
and children forms and um and so the
woman felt that the best way to protect
her children
was to not have the father around but it
turned out and that that that was the
worst way to protect her children
because of the children without children
without a dad are most vulnerable now
we've known this since
1965 when the moynihan report came out
and
daniel patrick moynihan was a
sociologist a u.s senator a department
of labor
a cabinet executive under both
republicans and democratic presidents
and he
was asked because he had such
qualifications to do a report of what
was created crime in the inner city and
everybody was going oh my god this is
going to end up you know blaming crime
on blacks because we know that in the
inner city very frequently blacks commit
crimes and
what came out was a very different
report than many people expected and
which was that that crimes were not
created by blacks per se
that crimes were created by the that
those people
in the inner city who were being raised
uh without debts
and that at the time in 1965 was 25
of the males in the inner city uh
almost all blacks um that that would be
among black males
among black families uh 25
of the children were being raised
without their dads in 1965.
today
the percentage is more than 70
among black males
among caucasian males at the 1965
it was only 3.2
of caucasian males that were being
raised without their dads today
it is 35 percent of caucasian males
being raised without their dads so the
caucasian males being raised without
their dens today
is higher than it was for black males in
1965 and we're seeing a huge amount of
dysfunction among both black males and
caucasian males today
and much
more among caucasian males than we were
seeing among black males in the
1960s and mid 60s do we know why
yes because the lack of father
involvement
leads many boys to feel that that they
um
they don't usually have postponed
gratification so i'll give i'll give you
an example
of what happens so
moms and dads tend to set boundaries the
same way they both care about their
children they say sweetie you can't have
your ice cream until you finish your
peas
children intended to test boundaries the
same way
they want to have as few peas as
possible before they get their ice cream
the difference between moms and dads on
average and sometimes this is reverse
the roles are reversed on average the
the um difference is that when the child
says to mom you know i don't want to
have my p's i had a bad day in school
today i was bullied by somebody where
the mom and dad are divorced and then
mom feels guilty about the divorce and
that feels this the child must be very
stressed
her empathy tends to step forward about
uh and she says to herself some version
of i'm not going to get into a big
argument about a few p's this is
ridiculous now when they're married and
the father does get in
in forces they can't have the peace
until the um the uh they can't have the
ice cream until they have the peas uh
the mother feels the dad is being
insensitive uh when they're divorced and
the thoughts and the children are going
over to the father's house the father
says i'm sorry we had a deal here now
the deal is you can't have your ice
cream until you finish your beans and
the child says you're so mean you know
mom that lets me have my peas when i've
had a bad day like this and so with her
dad the children learn that they have to
focus on finishing their peas
in order to get
their ice cream
and because that's not going to give in
and empathy will not
the the the child cannot coerce or
manipulate the father's emotions in
order to get the ice cream uh before he
finishes the piece
whereas with mom the child is learning
ah i can manipulate a better deal here
mom says okay i know you're you know
you've had a bad day so i'll tell you
what just have half the piece and so the
child realizes ah this is negotiable so
it begins to try to have half the half a
piece and um and then and then the mom
says okay i'm again the child at least
tried it's had they've had a bad day
okay so now the child is learning that
with mom i can manipulate better deals
and so the skill set that the child with
mom often learns is that of manipulation
but also a lack of respect for the mom's
boundaries
and so the mom finds herself repeating
and repeating the boundaries um
and where dad
after a while does not have to repeat it
because dad's made clear
that when the child does not finish the
peas
there's no ice cream so the child learns
to focus on doing what he or she needs
to do
in order to get what she or he wants the
ice cream and so the child is learning
with the dad is postponed gratification
and as most people know post bone
gratification is the single biggest
predictor of success or failure so the
boy without postponing gratification
goes to school uh has homework to finish
but is much more likely to get
sidetracked by an invitation from a
friend to play a video game and so or he
has a real great of potential as a
basketball or a football player or as an
actor or a musician but he doesn't have
the discipline um to uh to become one of
the best actors musicians basketball
players
so other is beat him out that are even
less talented than he is for that role
and he begins to feel ashamed of himself
and sometimes depressed and again no
girls are interested in the losers
they're interested in the winners and so
he starts turning in on himself and
becoming withdrawn and his own only
friends are the online friends that he
doesn't have real friends that will help
him move or do something when it really
counts and so this leads to depression
and in worst-case scenarios uh the
increase in suicides and a lot of that
comes from not having a dad
that is there to
guide him to help him take risks to help
him be disciplined at doing what he
wants to do
moms are very good at helping their
children both girls and boys identify
their talents and pursue them but very
frequently the children without a dad
does not have the discipline to
successfully become outstanding at the
most fulfilling things you want to be an
engineer or um you need um you need that
discipline but also if you want to be an
artist a writer a musician if you want
to ever make a living at it
or a basketball player and join the nba
you've got to be extremely disciplined
uh that was great so on your points
you've written here you know in the book
the christ of education christ and
mental health christ the father christ
of fathering purpose
all that stuff but
how much how much of um
the crisis i know you said yeah 10 so i
don't know the other six what they were
but how much do you think the role of
media and movies play
in uh who this kid wants to be meaning
uh i'm growing up who's the hero if the
hero to me was like this strong
military general uh you know what when i
grow up i want to be general patton or
whatever you know when i grow up i want
to be like you know uh
a john f kennedy i want to be like
reagan i want to be like whoever it is i
want to be like uh
you know um
clint eastwood i mean he's a man's man
you know i want to be like this guy
how much has the media change would
portray
who the ideal male is
that is loved admired and respected and
does that have a big influence on how
boys adjust
to get that necessary attention like oh
my gosh today's boys are a little bit
more silly i'm going to be silly because
that gets the right attention versus man
today's men are strong i want to be
strong because that gets the respect i
want do you think media plays a big role
in that
you know media does play an important a
very important role um and
we still have the same basic image of
men uh today um
on one level uh that is the man that the
woman is interested in and attracted to
is some version of superman however the
images of the father on tv
are the archie bunkers are the um you
know the fathers that are just um that
are the that are the goofballs and
the
analysis of advertising on tv where one
parent is focused um uh it looks like a
jerk or looks like a bumble you know a
well-intended but bumbling um parent
is not 90
males as dads that are looked at away
but 100
males when there's only one parent being
portrayed as a jerk
100 of the time on your advertising
it is the male being portrayed as some
version of the jerk or a well-intended
but bumbling sort of quasi idiot if you
will and so we've gone to from father
knows best
to fathers no less
as in our media images of dads and so
it's the dad image that has really been
um
neglected that said
there is recently an increasing number
of positive father images and
advertising
and that's uh and that's but there's
nothing close to what i feel needs to
happen uh when i spoke to when i greece
the white house of the the white house
but i briefed the white house on the boy
crisis book uh one of the things i
talked with them about is developing a
father warrior program w-a-r-r not
worker um but warrior program um to
encourage boys to um overcome the social
biases uh that it takes uh to become to
be valued as a dad uh right now if you
if a girl in college or young woman in
college uh approaches a male in college
at a at a party let's say and she says
oh you know let's you know what are you
um planning to do when you get out of
college and he says oh i want to be a
full-time dad
uh she's you know she's likely to find a
journalist um in the in the room to come
back and interview him
but she's likely to not come back for a
second and drink herself and so the guy
gets the hint that you know i'm an
aspiration to be a full-time dad or uh
while the woman goes off and maybe
earns the primary source of income or
all the source of income
that's the role that would be perfectly
fine for her to play and he will be
still attracted to her if she said that
she wants to be the primary parent
but very few he gets it that very few
women are going to come back and and
want to be with him if that's what he
states as his life goal
yeah i have a friend who's a full-time
dad and the wife works and they've been
together for 12 years 13 years
and happily married so
are you starting to see an increase in
that and if yes why
yes there is an increase in that
fortunately why though
why why is that happening
because there is an increased amount
well first of all um we are now at a
place where
two out of three
of the people who graduate from college
are female
not
not 60 40 60 40 are the ones that enter
college but among college graduates the
ratio is two female to one male
so 60 40 get into college but men
males in college are much less likely to
graduate from college for a lot of
reasons but the emphasis the the end
product is uh the woman where we're
twice as likely to have young women who
are recent college graduates um that we
are a male who's a recent college
graduate so the the female is oftentimes
um
as available to her
men who
may be good-looking maybe taller than
she
um but she knows that she's going to be
earning more money than he
and so then a big issue a big issue
happens
is she wants to be a habitable woman and
she's really interested in um you know
in developing uh you know breaking a
glass ceiling uh she knows that to do
that but she usually wants to have to be
a habitable woman she wants to be
happily married and she wants to have
children and children that are well
raised
so she begins to adjust to say well one
way that i can do that is to marry a man
who is a nurturer connector type of man
as opposed to a provider protector type
of man and um but um oftentimes and she
does that and the marriage will that
type of marriage that is a woman who is
the primary breadwinner and a man who's
home taking care of the children
if she truly respects him
that marriage has a high percentage
chance of working out very well
so two things three things have to be in
place she has to really want to be a
career person and want to have a lot of
her approval and respect for the korean
person
she has to adjust ahead of time to the
fact that the man that she can respect
the man who's taking care of the
children well
taking care of the social schedule
cooking the dinner as well and so on and
as she loses respect for him and she
if she gets attracted to another man at
work who's really successful who also
seems to be attracted to her
that can make her divided in her love
and the marriage will very frequently
end
but if she
has the fortitude to know that the
reason she has a happy marriage and and
the man is raising children that men
will only
do that
with gusto
if they feel the respect from their
wives
because almost every man instinctively
knows that a woman who does not respect
a man is not able to love that man
so so in the case of jeff bezos
and mackenzie
you have a mckenzie marital guy who
who's now the richest man in the world
and they get a divorce
and she goes and marries a school
teacher got him dan i don't know jewett
or some some you know
you know
nice guy i'm sure but he's a school
teacher so you go from here to here
is there is there also an element of i
am so burned out with being with a
driven alpha guy that i just want a
regular guy like you know how we go
through a breakup we're dramatic right
we'll go from
somebody that is you know driven
competitive you're like oh my gosh she's
so attractive to me and overbearing like
i just want to date a regular girl and
then you're like oh my gosh i'm so bored
and you go back to this why why do we
why do we and the reason why is this
question from you is because you brought
up your first wife and i think your
first wife was a mathematician i may be
wrong i think she was a mathematician or
either you were a mathematician or she
was a mathematician and you guys were
married for night for 10 years you spoke
very highly about her here on the
uh you know
interview and then your second wife i
think has been together for 20 years now
i i want to say it's 20 years give or
take a little over 20 years so
where do we get
marriage wrong like
i don't even know if most most men even
know like
the purpose of getting married like what
we're looking for are we confused half
the time when we're getting married
yes to be fair and honest um both sexes
tend to fall in love with the members of
the other sex who are the uh who are
often opposites and and often the least
capable of loving them uh so men fall in
love with beautiful younger women who
are less mature uh than they are and end
up um being very highly you know look up
looking up to the man at the beginning
and we feel really proud and approved of
and so on um but then it turns out that
we're a little bit disgusted in their
lack of maturity and they're disgusted
at our uh propensity for dominating and
and having all the answers and the more
mature she becomes the more she wants to
have an equality in the relationship
which was different from the dynamic
that attracted the two of them
but there's a lot of bigger issues that
often happen here too so the jeff bezos
case i don't know the situation
personally but normally speaking or very
frequently as a sort of model um the the
woman will initially be attracted to a
man who is very successful powerful dumb
confident in himself able to be has a
sense of efficacy um and so um but she
doesn't realize that it's ex
but that it's exactly those
characteristics that will lead to their
divorce here's why
so
what both sexes have an equal need for
is a need to feel heard and understood
but as the male
who is successful becomes more and more
successful he often learns a series of
behaviors that are
that are that help him become successful
at work
that is are exactly the behaviors that
lead him to be unsuccessful in love so
for example let's say you're a ceo and
you're looking for a a new type of plane
and you get a sales person trying to
sell you a special engine um that they
have for a new plane that will that they
say will be perfect for you well as as a
ceo you're listening to that sales
person speak and you're thinking to
yourself okay is this salesperson as
convincing as another salesperson i had
before and should i also interview
somebody else will this work for my
chinese market well will this work for
these infrastructure that i already have
set up for my chinese market uh will
this um you know and and is asking a
hundred questions like this
while the person is talking
um and so that person the a good ceo has
learned to self listen
um to be juggling the listening process
with the uh with the yes but process or
what about process and the
cross-examination process
that skill set for the good ceo becomes
so ingrained
that when he takes that that skill set
home and by the way this can sometimes
be happened to women as well
not as frequently but i'll explain why
both frequently and not frequently so
that the male sales of the male ceo
comes home
and his wife says you know i've had a
really difficult day at work or i've had
a difficulty with the children but
something's happened in the family and
um and the male
sees his wife the woman he loves the
woman he'd probably die for
um to is having a problem and so our
instinct when our wife is having a
problem is to while she's talking to
figure out a solution because
instinctively when our wife who i we
love is bleeding to death the only way
to handle that is to solve the problem
to get the band-aids on her quickly to
get it to the emergency room quickly and
so um we we're we're behaving with our
wife in a way that is looking for the
solution while she's talking
very few ceos or top level entrepreneurs
realize that there is a solution for
your wife's complaints and challenges
and that is to listen
not only listen by keeping your mouth
shut
but also listen by when she's finished
the complaining not coming up with a
solution
but rather saying so sweetie what i
heard you say was was this is and then
asking is that accurate and then if she
says no actually it's mostly accurate
thank you for listening but i i think
you got this wrong not saying no no i
said that
not becoming defensive about what she
feels we got wrong but being right in
there saying so it's not what i said but
it's this is that correct and then she
goes yes that's correct okay did i miss
anything and uh understanding what
you're saying
um yes i think you've missed this no no
no i think i got that i said that
because this no
shut your mouth listen
work on what she feels you miss because
the only thing that counts
is what she feels that you've missed and
then when she begins to feel safe
because you didn't distort anything you
didn't miss anything say is there
anything new that you'd like to add
that leads to a woman or when a woman
does the same thing for a man in reverse
that leads to your partner feeling heard
but the great majority of men
move to fixing the problem
as opposed to understanding that you can
fix the problem by not fixing the
problem the fixing of the problem is the
listening process
hearing
and then letting your wife or your
daughter or your son
say
here's what i heard you say son
daughter wife
uh mom dad
um and then mom and dad daughter wife
uh she a son feels really hurt
and then
and being open to anything you distorted
open anything that you missed
and so this is what i teach in my
couple's communication courses in much
greater depth than i've explained here
and invariably one of the men in the
chorus will say well no i'm not really
fixing it then i'm not really attending
to
her real need she's hurting why am i not
solving the problem for her and i have
to work with him that hearing the
listening process
in the way i just described it is the
solution
the fixing of it leaves your wife
children or parents feeling unheard
people need to be heard
before they are asking for a solution
beyond being heard
so let me let me ask you a question i
think i'm getting a read on what you're
saying are you insinuating that we
should add term limits to marriage
absolutely not um the term limits to
marriage should be
there should be no term limit to
marriage like i'm talking like you get
married four years and you campaign with
all the family i think we should go one
more four years
you are you saying that's a good idea
term limits
yeah so you can do it that way but i
think the the um i i think it's the
second best way of doing it i think
that's giving you a hard
let's this time i was i was involved
with my wife for 27 years and we took
eight years before we decided to we
actually got married and during those of
um first eight years it was sort of like
you know re-examining whether this was
the right person for us we were very
different people and so we really needed
my couple's communication course to
really hear each other really well
in order to see that the differences
made much less differences the
difference in the love we had
then um 17 years ago we got married
married and my attitude when i got
married
i'm in this forever
um you know there's no
i may find another woman attracted but
i've made my commitment and
and that
level of commitment that i made when i
got married really was meaningful to me
and there's there are things that
happened in the ceremony of marriage in
the ceremony of marriage you bring the
people you love and care for around you
they see you make that commitment when
you make that commitment and you see the
people you love
see you make that commitment something
changes in your brain your r c z your
rostral cingulate zone in your brain
is is special knowing that the people
who you love are approving of you
getting married and they will approve of
you more when you remain married and
that gives you a little extra oomph to
go through the hard times um to um to to
work things through that are that are
challenging and then we had the couple's
communication course where
the the
the the very
disciplined process of teaching men and
women how to listen to each other uh
that goes beyond anything that i've seen
um so far so let me um is if you don't
mind going to the the the because i only
have like seven minutes and i want to
make sure i get these two other
questions in there as well uh in on in
the area of pay gap
so you know it's a very common debate
that you always hear on the political
side that happens well women are not
getting paid it's not fair it's not this
so one side says female athletes should
get paid as much as male athletes and
then the argument will be made as female
athletes in certain sports like
gymnastics is more but maybe in
basketball it's not more doesn't get as
many viewership as male athletes do
where did this pay gap argument come in
and does it have any credence uh and if
it does in certain industry is there
some areas where it has no credence in
yes well first of all this is such an
important question that i literally
wrote an entire book to answer this
question
called why men earn more the startling
truth behind the pay gap and what women
can do about it and the most important
part of why men earn more i think is my
discussion of the 25 differences between
what men do
in the workplace
and in their work life balance and what
women do in their work life balance
so
some quick insights
never married men
and never married women
who have never had children
that never married women out earn and
their married men
by 17
and the never married women who have
never had children
have out earned the never married men
who have never had children
since the 70s wow
that gives you some sense that
the pay gap predominantly
is not just about these 20 is about
these 25 different um decisions
that men and women make but it's usually
not just men and women or single men and
women
it is rather
married men and women with children the
pay gap is much much less about men and
women than it is about dads versus moms
when dads become dads
they tend to
um
give up jobs that they are fulfilling
that pay less
they love being an elementary school
teacher but they realize that being a
superintendent of schools or a principal
will pay them twice as much even though
they hate administration
so they give up becoming that passionate
elementary school teacher to do
something that will support their family
better they love being a musician an
artist a writer or an actor
but they all pay very little and
starving artists so they give up those
gigs and that those passions of
fulfillment to pace to get something
that pays more
but the more fulfilling the job the less
it pays on average the road to high pay
is a toll road men when they become
when they're just men who are who don't
have children they they want to do
what's fulfilling like women do but when
they have children they're willing to
give up doing what's fulfilling to and
look at the things that pay more that
they may like a lot less that they
usually do like a lot less work more
hours than they want to work because
their job is no longer to please
themselves their job is to make sure
that their wife and children are secure
and move to good neighborhoods with good
schools and that their wife that their
children have opportunities that they've
never had as a result of those
sacrifices and so that's where the pay
gap resides
and if you wish to really understand the
pay gap look at those 25 differences and
work life choices and i'll explain
explain in the white men and learn more
book exactly what those differences are
worth financially and why the great
majority of men do work that they like
less that earns more and the great
majority of women are more likely to do
more fulfilling jobs that earn less and
if you really do want to earn more
you could look at any of those 25
careers and jobs and decisions that men
and women make
that lead to earning more money but
usually the earning of more money leads
to less fulfillment
so i asked i asked you earlier i said
our goal on today's zoom is to be able
to solve the boy crisis in 59 minutes
i think we're making some progress i
don't know what you say about that but i
think we made some progress today doc i
appreciate you for uh getting on the
zoom here i've really enjoyed talking to
you we're gonna put the link below to
your book
uh the boy crisis uh below for people to
be able to find it we'll also put the
link to your website where folks can go
and find you but with that being said
thank you so much for your time and
being a guest on valuetainment
it's a total pleasure i also want to say
that a lot of men tell me that they
commute or they're working out of the
gym and the audible version is really
more helpful for them to take in the um
the um the boy crisis book fantastic
we'll put the link below thank you very
much great to take care real life
so do you think there's a boy crisis yes
there is thumbs up no i don't think
there's a boy crisis thumbs down uh but
i thought it was very interesting cena's
perspective if you want to get his book
we'll put the link below if you enjoyed
this interview i did another interview
with jordan peterson
this was uh at the same event when i
interviewed kobe the late kobe bryant
and george bush if you've never seen
this interview with jordan peterson it's
a must-watch click over here to watch it
and if you haven't subscribed to the
channel please do so thanks for watching
everybody take care bye